mais d'abord quel avenir politique pour
l'ancienne premier adjointe à la mairie
de Tours katiemunch Masset était jugé en
appel ce mardi après-midi devant le
tribunal d'Orléans dans l'affaire de
détournement de fonds publics au
détriment de la page 37 une association
d'aide aux personnes handicapées 350
000 eurosité sur son compte en banque
entre 2018 et 2020 condamné en premier
instant socialiste a toujours nié sa
connaissance des faits reportant la
responsabilité sur son mari aujourd'hui
sa stratégie de défense est restée la
même compte rendu d'audience avec Romain
Delville
tendance à tour elle le répète d'une
voix forte bien qu’essoufflée elle
n'avait pas connaissance de la situation
catastrophique des finances du couple y
compris les 12 emprunts à la
consommation est-ce que vous aviez des
œillères demande la cour qui pousse
l'ancienne vice-présidente de la Région
dans ses retranchements en mars dernier
le tribunal correctionnel a condamné
qu'a-t-il Munch à 18 mois de prison avec
sursis et 5 ans d'inné éligibilité le
procès en appel ici à Orléans est
toujours en cours